TUCKER CARLSON IS STANDING BY.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER
CARLSON TONIGHT."
IF YOU'VE BEEN WATCHING TV
TODAY, YOU KNOW THAT THOUSANDS
OF CHILDREN WALKED OUT OF SCHOOL
ACROSS AMERICA DEMANDING THE
PASSAGE OF NEW GUN-CONTROL LAWS
FOLLOWING THE MASS SHOOTING IN
PARKLAND FLORIDA OF COURSE.
THE WALKOUT WAS BEING HANDLED BY
AN ACT OF BRAVERY, BUT OF COURSE
STUDENTS DO NOT ACT
INDEPENDENTLY.
THEY CAN'T ACT INDEPENDENTLY,
THEY'RE UNDER CONTROL OF ADULTS,
IN THIS CASE BY DEFINITION,
THEY'RE IN SCHOOL.
WHEN HE HEARD A 16-YEAR-OLDS IN
SCHOOL SCREAM HOW MANY DID YOU
KILL TODAY?
YOU CAN BE CERTAIN ADULTS ARE
BEHIND IT MAR.
TODAY'S EVENTS WAS ORGANIZED BY
THE WOMEN'S MARCH.
CELEBRITIES, JOURNALISTS,
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY TRIED
THEM ON AN TV CHANNEL
NICKELODEON WENT DARK FOR
17 MINUTES TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR
"KIDS LEADING THE WAY."
IN NEW YORK CITY, ANDREW CUOMO
JOINED IN AND IN BALTIMORE, THAT
CITY SPENT 100 GRAND TO
TRANSPORT STUDENTS TO ANTI-GUN
RALLIES.
THEY CANNOT AFFORD TRASH CANS OR
STREETLIGHTS.
MEANWHILE IN VIRGINIA, 65
STUDENTS WALKED OUT OF AN
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL AS OF KIDS
UNDER TEN CAN GO ANYWHERE BY
THEMSELVES.
WHETHER YOU LIKE THE KIDS AND
YOU LIKE WHAT THEY'RE SAYING,
YOU SHOULD BE OPPOSED TO THIS
BECAUSE KIDS SHOULD NOT BE USED
TO ADVANCE POLITICAL AGENDA AND
ITS        .
THAT'S WHY THEY CAN'T VOTE OR A
DRINK OR BUY GUNS.
THEY'RE BEING EXPLOITED AND
THAT'S WHAT THE LEFT HAS ALWAYS
DONE.
SOUTH AFRICA USED KIDS AS
PROPAGANDA IN THE '80s.
CAUSES USUALLY ARE MORALLY
DEFENSIBLE.
AN ENTIRE GENERATION OF KIDS
GROW UP TO LEARN THAT ACTIVISM
IS MORE IMPORTANT THAN LEARNING
AND A LOT OF THEM REGRET IT NOW,
THEY WERE EXPLOITED AND THERE
BEING EXPLOITED HERE.
NO MATTER WHAT THEY CHANT, THE
ENEMY OF THE ADULTS BEHIND THIS
ISN'T THE NRA, IT'S ANYONE WHO
OPPOSES THEIR BROADER AGENDA.
THAT'S PEOPLE WHO HAVE NO POWER
AT ALL.
THE MESSAGE IS SIMPLE, STAND
AGAINST US AND YOU'RE AGAINST
CHILDREN AND THEREFORE YOU'RE A
MONSTER AND IF YOU'RE A MONSTER,
YOU DESERVE TO BE DESTROYED.
IT'S KIND OF MORAL BLACKMAIL.
IGOR, THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
MY COMPLAINT IS NOT THAT PEOPLE
DISAGREE WITH HIM A
SECOND AMENDMENT.
MY FIRST PROBLEM IS THE USE OF
CHILDREN TO MAKE A POLITICAL
POINT.
WOULD YOU, FOR EXAMPLE, I KNOW
YOU SUPPORT WHAT HAPPENED TODAY,
HAVE A PROBLEM IF THESE KIDS
WERE BEING DRIVEN BY THEIR
TEACHERS AND BUSES TO AN NRA
RALLY OR IF THEY WERE REGULATING
AGAINST TRANSGENDER BATHROOMS?
HOW WOULD YOU FEEL ABOUT THAT?
>> I LOVE THE STUDENTS WHO ARE
OUT THERE ENGAGING THE
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS, STUDENTS WHO
WERE DOING WHAT TEACHERS WANT
THEM TO DO, WITH TEACHERS TEACH
THEM TO DO AND THAT IS TAKE PART
IN CRITICAL THINKING, FIND SOME
SOMETHING THEY BELIEVE IN AND
FIGHT FOR IT.
YOU SAW THE STUDENTS --
>> Tucker: YOU DIDN'T ANSWER
MY QUESTION.
IF THEY WERE TAKEN TO PRO-LIFE
MARCHES OR SOMETHING YOU
DISAGREED WITH, HOW WOULD YOU
FEEL?
WOULD YOU SAY THAT'S TOTALLY
COOL?
>> A HYPOTHETICAL QUESTION OF DO
I THINK STUDENTS SHOULD BE TAKEN
AGAINST THEIR WILL?
>> Tucker: NO, IF TEACHERS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY WERE SENDING
KIDS SAYING LET ME HELP YOU GET
TO EMERGE, THAT REPRESENTED
SOMETHING YOU FOUND MORALLY
REPUGNANT, WOULD YOU BE
SUPPORTIVE ON PRINCIPLE?
>> IF YOUR PREMISE IS SHOULD
STUDENTS BE TAKEN SOMEWHERE BY
TEACHERS WHERE THEY DON'T WANT
TO GO, I AGREE THAT SHOULDN'T
HAPPEN.
YOU HEARD THE STUDENTS AFTER THE
SHOOTING, YOU HEARD WITH THE
STUDENTS SAID, THEY BELIEVE IN
THEIR GUT AND THE REASON IS THAT
THEY'VE EXPERIENCED THESE
BULLETS, THEY BURIED THEIR
CLASSMATES.
NOBODY'S FORCING THAT.
>> Tucker: KIDS WHO ARE UNDER
THE CARE OF A TEACHER WHO HAS
CONTROL OF THEIR GRADES AND LIFE
ARE NOT FREE AGENTS.
THEY CAN'T ACT FULLY
INDEPENDENTLY AS YOU AND I CAN
BECAUSE THERE UNDER THE CONTROL
OF AN AUTHORITY FIGURE.
THIS IS REALLY SIMPLE, THIS IS
WHY TEACHERS AREN'T ALLOWED TO
HAVE SEX WITH STUDENTS.
SO WHY ARE TEACHERS ALLOWED TO
DIRECT KIDS?
IT'S SIMPLE.
>> BECAUSE THEY TEACHERS ARE NOT
DIRECTING STUDENTS TO DO
ANYTHING.
THIS IS A STUDENT LEAD.
THIS IS THE POWER OF THIS
MOVEMENT OF THIS MOMENT IS THAT
NOW WE ARE IN A SITUATION WHERE
STUDENTS ARE SAYING ENOUGH IS
ENOUGH FROM THE LAWMAKERS WHO
DON'T WANT TO CHANGE THE GUN
LAWS, ENOUGH IS ENOUGH FROM THE
NRA WHO WANTS TO POST THEIR GUNS
EVERYWHERE.
THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE DOING.
THAT'S WHAT'S INSPIRING ABOUT
ALL OF THIS.
>> Tucker: IF I CAN MAKE AN
OBVIOUS POINT WHICH IS THAT KIDS
CAN'T VOTE, KIDS OF THE AGE OF
MOST OF THE STUDENTS,
16-YEAR-OLDS CAN'T VOTE, SO
THEY'RE ACTUALLY NOT IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS AND WE'VE
AGREED THAT THEY SHOULDN'T BE IN
THE DEMOCRATIC PROCESS, WE'VE
AGREED THAT UNTIL THEY CAN MAKE
RATIONAL DECISIONS, THEY CAN'T
VOTE AND BY THE WAY, YOU DON'T
WANT THEM TO BUY GUNS.
IF THEY'RE TOO YOUNG TO BUY
GUNS, WHY SHOULD THEY BE MAKING
MY GUN LAWS?
I'M ASKING YOU WHAT YOU THINK.
WHY SHOULD PEOPLE WHO DON'T HAVE
A RIGHT TO BUY GUNS HAVE THE
RIGHT TO MAKE MY GUN LAWS?
IS A SIMPLE QUESTION.
>> THEY ARE NOT MAKING MY GUN
LAWS.
AS CITIZENS IN THIS COUNTRY,
THEY ARE ALLOWED --
>> Tucker: THEIR CHILDREN,
THEIR AMERICANS, BUT THEY AREN'T
ADULTS.
THEY CAN'T DRINK ALCOHOL, A LOT
OF THEM CAN'T DRIVE CARS.
MY DIFFERENCE BETWEEN AN ADULT
AND A CHILD.
>> UP MY POINT IS, THEY'VE BEEN
PLACED IN THIS SITUATION WHERE
THEIR WIVES ARE IN DANGER IN
AMERICAN SCHOOLS AND THE REASON
IS BECAUSE OF DECISIONS THAT
LAWMAKERS MADE AND BECAUSE OF
THE AGENDA OF THE NRA THAT WANTS
TO PUT EVEN MORE GUNS IN THEIR
CLASSROOMS.
I THINK IT'S UNKNOWABLE FOR
THEM --
>> Tucker: IF ONE OF THEIR
TEACHERS, SOME SCARY ALT-RIGHT
PERSON WAS TAKEN THEM TO A MILO
RALLY, YOU'D BE FREAKING OUT.
IF THERE WERE 50,000 KIDS GOING
TO A MYLA RALLY RIGHT NOW TAKEN
BY THEIR TEACHERS FROM
FORT WORTH, YOU WOULD SAY THIS
IS THE END OF AMERICA.
>> WHAT THEY BELIEVE IN THIS.
TUCKER, YOU HAVE STUDENTS BURY
THEIR FRIENDS.
YOU HAD STUDENTS WHO LOSE
FRIENDS AND THAT HAPPENS ALL
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
>> Tucker: WHAT YOU'RE DOING
IS ENGAGING IN THE CLASSIC MORAL
BLACKMAIL TECHNIQUES.
YOU SAY IF YOU OPPOSE WHAT I
BELIEVE, YOU ARE AGAINST.
LET ME ASK A RATIONAL QUESTION.
YOU HAVE SENT OUT A NUMBER OF
TWEETS SAYING THE COPS ARE
RACIST.
I'M NOT ATTACKING YOU.
I'M TRYING TO GET TO A QUESTION.
IF YOU BELIEVE THAT THE POLICE
HAVE A PROBLEM WITH RACIST
VIOLENCE, WHY DO YOU WANT THE
POLICE TO BE THE ONLY PEOPLE TO
HAVE GUNS?
IT'S A SIMPLE QUESTION.
>> I DON'T WANT THE POLICE TO
BEGIN WITH PEOPLE WHO HAVE GUNS.
I WANT TO MOVE US TO A COUNTRY
WHERE WE HAVE FEWER GUNS AND WE
DON'T HAVE AN ASSAULT WEAPONS
BACK AND KILL PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: THE COMPS YOU
DESCRIBED AS RACIST, DO THEY
HAVE ASSAULT WEAPONS?
>> I'M ARGUING THAT RACISM PLAYS
A ROLE IN THE DISPROPORTIONATE
MURDER OF YOUNG BLACK MEN.
>> Tucker: THIN WIRE YOU SO
TRUSTING OF THESE PEOPLE?
>> I WANT TO HAVE A SERIOUS
CONVERSATION.
WE WERE LAUGHING.
>> Tucker: NUMEROUS CHILDREN
WENT OUT OF THEIR WAY TO PANDER.
>> WE NEED LAWS, NOT NICE
THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS.
>> OF THE NRA HAS MADE A PUBLIC
ENEMY NUMBER ONE AND I'M PROUD
OF IT.
>> ARE YOU GOING TO VOTE OUT OF
OFFICE THE PEOPLE WHO TAKE THE
GUN LOBBY MONEY?
>> THE NRA HAS HELD CONGRESS
HOSTAGE >> WE NEED A VOTE MALM
WE NEED A VOTE NOW.
>> Tucker: WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF
THIS MARCH?
>> A COUPLE OF THINGS ARE GOING
ON AND YOUR PRIOR GAS TO,
NANCY PELOSI DID IT.
IT WAS A RALLY THAT WAS SUPPOSED
TO TARGET SCHOOL VIOLENCE, NOT
PASS LEGISLATIVE ITEMS, BUT
SHAME ON US FOR BRINGING IT UP.
WHERE THE ONES WHO ARE THE KIDS.
FIRST HE DID THE APPEAL TO
EMOTION WHERE THEY TALK ABOUT
EMOTION AS IF A MOTION IS REASON
IN THIS CASE.
OF COURSE WE ALL FEEL HORRIBLE
FOR WHAT HAPPENED IN PARKLAND.
THERE IS NO DISPUTE THERE, BUT
WHAT HE DOES IS HE CONFUSES THE
EMOTION SURROUNDING THE
SITUATION WITH REASON AND
REASONABLE MEASURES GOING
FORWARD WOULD REDUCE SCHOOL
VIOLENCE.
HE DID SOMETHING ELSE THAT I
FOUND PARTICULARLY DISTURBING.
LIBERALS DO THIS ALL THE TIME.
THEY DO THIS UTOPIAN FALLACY
WHERE THEY SAY THINGS THAT ARE
CLEARLY NONSENSICAL DESIGNED TO
MAKE YOU LOOK FOOLISH.
WHAT THEY DO IS THEY SAY THINGS
LIKE WE ALL WANT FEWER GUNS IN
SCHOOL.
OF COURSE WE DO, BUT YOU DON'T
GET TO PICK THAT.
THE BAD GUIDE DOES.
YOU THINK THE BAD GUY WALKS IN
THE SCHOOL AND GOES "THERE'S A
SIGN UP THAT SAYS WE WANT FEWER
GUNS IN SCHOOL, LET ME TURN
AROUND" WE DON'T LIVE IN A
UTOPIA IN A PERFECT WORLD AND
IT'S INFURIATING HAVING A DEBATE
WITH PEOPLE WHO CONSTANTLY
ENGAGE IN THESE SILLY TACTICS,
NEVER WANT TO GET ANYTHING
REASONABLE DONE, AND THEY DO IT
STRICTLY TO MAKE YOU LOOK SILLY.
>> Tucker: HOW WOULD YOU FEEL
IF YOUR CHILD'S TEACHER WAS
PRIVATIZING ABOUT A SPECIFIC
POINT OF VIEW AND THEN BROUGHT
THEM TO A POLITICAL RALLY,
WOULDN'T YOU HAVE A RIGHT TO BE
OUTRAGED AND SAY THAT'S NOT WHY
YOU'RE SENDING THEM TO SCHOOL?
>> I'D BE PRETTY PISSED.
I SENT MY KIDS TO SCHOOL FOR
READING, WRITING, AND ARITHMETIC
READING, WRITING, AND ARITHMETI
ARITHMETIC.
I, UNLIKE A LOT OF LIBERALS
ENCOURAGE MY DAUGHTERS TO GO
BACK TO SCHOOL AND MAKE THEIR
CASE AND MAKE IT AND A
REASONABLE FASHION.
IF THE TEACHER GIVES THEM A BAD
GRADE, WE CAN FIGHT THAT FIGHT,
BUT THAT'S WHAT REASONABLE
PEOPLE DO.
THEY DON'T ENCOURAGE KIDS TO
WALK OUT OF SCHOOL DURING THE
MIDDLE OF THE DAY.
GOD FORBID ONE OF THESE KIDS
WALKING OUT OF SCHOOL WAS HIT BY
A CAR OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
I DON'T SEND MY KIDS TO SCHOOL
TO ENGAGE IN A POLITICAL
PROTEST.
>> Tucker: YOU OUGHT TO PULL
YOUR KIDS OUT IMMEDIATELY IF
THEY ARE EXPORTED THE WAY THESE